when you leave school a great day you
just have to figure it out by making
these mistakes I didn't pay my taxes for
four years I got a half a million dollar
tax bill Damon fryer has one of the
largest Automotive channels on YouTube
daily driven Exotics where he films the
reality of owning some of the most
expensive cars in the world so what's
the collective value of all your cars
4.7 million this multi-million dollar
collection includes multiple
Lamborghinis Ferraris McLarens and more
which often lands in quite a lot of
trouble with law enforcement as he
records for all of us to watch today
we're getting an inside look into the
realities of owning exotic cars how he
was able to build his wealth and all the
details about his police interactions
that he couldn't post on YouTube now
thank you Graham for that beautiful
intro as I'm sure you guys have all seen
our guest Damon films about every aspect
of his life and if you're interested in
getting started with content creation we
couldn't recommend more you get started
with stream yard stream yard is a live
streaming software that allows you to
start creating high quality content with
just the click of a button all you need
is a camera and inner internet
connection and you can begin creating
content and streaming right from your
browser you could stream to multiple
social media platforms all at the exact
same time including Facebook YouTube
LinkedIn and more so what you're trying
to say Graham is you basically get free
organic reach to every social media
platform as long as you sign up for the
social media platform and click the
button on stream yard of course then
yeah I guess so they also offer various
analytics tools to measure the success
of each one of your live streams and
knowing which platforms are driving the
most traffic is going to help you
optimize to get even more views in the
future seriously guys stream yard is the
best way to start creating high quality
content without having to spend any
money they also offer a free package so
that means you can get started today
with absolutely no money they've also
been a long time supporter of the
podcast so it would mean a ton if you
guys signed up with that link Down Below
in the description so check out stream
yard today with the link Down Below in
the description and now let's get to the
podcast welcome back to the ice coffee
hour here with Graham and Jack you're
here with Damon fryer from daily driven
Exotics how I was out for an intro that
was amazing it was really good thank you
that might be the best intro we've ever
had on the podcast I agree with that
yeah that was really good but on top of
that first take you also pulled up and
not one but two Lamborghinis
correct two Lamborghinis what is the
reason for having too many Lambos Jack
no no the svj the svj and the event that
are s tell me about him they're
fantastic cars like the svj what's the
MSRP of that car if you if you could buy
one right now like 600 Grand I honestly
don't know because I'm not in the market
for one because I already have one but
when I was fortunate enough to get that
car I got it just before the market went
crazy
so I got that car for
uh Dave what was it again 666 I think we
paid for it Canadian right Canadian
Canadian 525 so 525 okay and then they
went nuts and people were selling them
or trying to sell them for over a
million dollars yeah like do you think
it's worth more now than it was when you
bought it it's uh yes I believe they're
all still up I don't believe as many
people are are actually getting the
sales on them I think a lot of people
are kind of in a holding pattern but I
believe everyone's still asking
something like that I feel like I gotta
ask this question because when we were
outside looking at your cars you were
like slapping that you weren't slapping
it around but you were like kind of
manhandling but you were touching your
car a lot you removed the entire Hood to
show us the engine you just set it on
the roof of the car and to me that like
broke my heart knowing how expensive
that car is does it not worry you to
just casually because you said you put
30 000 kilometers on it yeah it's uh
Thirty thirty three thousand I think at
the moment does it not bother you to to
drive such an expensive car or like
luxury good and no
um
for two reasons one you have to remember
the context the context is
I started a decade ago with a gyardo and
I also treated actually treated that car
technically a lot worse than I'm even
treating this current car but
you know I'd been doing this and the
idea was to daily Drive super cars to
show people because a decade ago it was
like nothing like it is today okay like
10 years a lot happens in 10 years
10 years ago if you saw a Lamborghini
driving around you know especially where
I live in Canada where there's four
seasons there's a lot of rain there's
snow so when there's snow there's salt
and sand that gets put on the road so
people the few and far between people
who had those cars really wouldn't drive
them you'd see them the odd time in
summer
I wanted to change all that 10 years ago
um my passion was to eventually be able
to afford an exotic car and I wanted to
if I was going to have said exotic car I
was gonna daily drive it that was the
whole idea like quite literally so when
you go into the idea of doing that you
can't Care at least where I live it's
not Southern California here in Las
Vegas where it's just sunny and dry and
the roads are just super clean and the
only thing that's really a technically
maybe abusing the car is like how many
miles you put on it or how hard you
drive it where just the elements are
beating the car up where we where we
live so you have to go into it like
obviously not caring about that you know
what I mean so from day one I went into
it with the idea that well I was just
going to treat this like any other car
so that's what I did and it escalated
from there so 10 so fast forward 10
years of quote unquote daily driving
daily using and
seeing and dealing with all the abuse
that comes with that I'm at a point
where I'm so numb now like it's just
been I've been so fortunate that that's
been my life for 10 years that when I
see that Lamborghini svj that you guys
are like the Lamborghini svj it's like
that to me too don't get me wrong I'm
very grateful and I do appreciate that
car for what it is
well to me it's like it's just a car it
still just takes gas has oil
has four tires can they handle the abuse
that you put it through 100 I'm always
so weary of that because I see so many
cars breaking down there's so many
issues or you do one thing and all of a
sudden it's like 30 grand to fix a
clutch because you reverse the wrong way
up a hill or like something goes wrong
do you find that happens or no no again
it it really depends on what period of
Supercar you own if you own a new modern
supercar
the technology the new systems the the
DCT Transmissions the newer engines
they're so good you know what I mean
like the Huracan is a perfect example
this is a car that was engineered uh at
the highest levels with I believe like
Audi and you know the Volkswagen group
and they're not handmade you know
murcielagos and countaches anymore like
those are the days when if you had one
of those cars they were very expensive
to maintain and they would be very
unreliable because they were put
together by some Italian gentleman
smoking a cigarette you know like you
know I like doing one card at a time or
whatever they did back in the day now
there's so much technology so like the
Huracan I always joke is the quite
literally the Honda Civic of our you
know Supercar world it's so reliable you
can doing one oil change a year and put
gas in it and drive it you know can you
get it fixed up at like an Audi
dealership or you probably could but I
think I think the way they want The
Branding to stay prestigious
they would turn you away but there are
so many Audi parts for the R8 for
example that are used also with the
Huracan it's the same as the same
transmission right yeah yeah the only
thing that it really changes is the
exterior look and the interior is
reconfigured to have a lot more space
and that's really due to the exterior
design sure like the huracan's so
aggressive like this wedge has to have
that Lamborghini you know uh flatness to
it exactly like silhouette yes they base
everything off so you recognize the
brand and when you do that to that car
it obviously decreases making that car
smaller the Interior Space where an R8
is essentially the same car but you get
in and you got so much more room so very
cool so uh tell us a little bit about
your backstory go back to ninth grade
because I remember hearing that you like
somewhat dropped out of school in ninth
grade actually so you dropped out in
eighth grade yeah you know both of my
pair reference
are College slash University educated
people
uh as you do from their generation and
um they were not very happy about it my
dad more
so less happy
the short version is
I didn't know then I mean I did that's
not true I was diagnosed with dyslexia
like a severe case of Dyslexia when I
was quite young because my parents I
live in Canada my parents put me in
French immersion they were like I'd be
cool you know like uh I have a sister
too they can learn a second language
so they put me in French immersion and I
failed grade one like horribly they're
like there's something obviously going
on with your son for the lack of a
better word there's something wrong with
your son and so I went to a series of
tests I vaguely remember this and um
came out of it with this diagnosis of
being very dyslexic and so with that uh
the challenge is reading now Reading
Writing
um just seeing the way I see words and
numbers like they don't make sense to me
and so what happened was
at that time versus again now you know
there were no computers there was no
teaching with like you know anything
alternative then other than like
lectures and a teacher standing at the
front of the room talking to you and
then textbooks so like everything was
like the worst way for me to learn so I
couldn't really can like absorb any
information
and so that was very frustrating but
somehow I made it through
you know all the way to grade grade
eight and at that point I was just my
grades were super awful and I started
kind of picking up on you know that I
was good with people because I grew up
in a family-run uh entrepreneurial
environment where my parents had a motel
and a restaurant and so I grew up in a
very adult environment getting my chores
were doing real work like what a young
teenager would call like their first job
that's what I did for chores I would do
like four hours of dinner service dishes
in a commercial grade kitchen like
cleaning dishes with my family's
restaurant and interacting with like the
waiters and the wait staff who were like
at best late teens early 20s right and
then whoever else in the business and
all the adults coming in and customers
so that was the environment I was
brought up in and
I knew in grade 8 that
my option was you know struggle through
school
hate my life
uh probably not do very well
and or
give up school and go work for the
family business so that was my proposal
to my parents my dad was like yeah no
you're going back to school but
unfortunately for my dad who only had us
every other weekend because my parents
went through a divorce and separated
when I was 12. he didn't I didn't live
with my dad I lived with my mom and my
mom at that time had taken over that
business from my dad when they split so
my mom still had that business so I just
went and worked with my mom my mom was
so busy that she just I just I took
advantage of the fact that I knew she
didn't have the time to like discipline
me to really pull me back in school like
she couldn't physically make me do that
so instead she was like okay like you're
gonna work with me and what's your dad
think about that I hated it
I'm sure my parents had some fights
behind closed doors over that one isn't
there a law that that like says you
can't do that or did your mom have to
like sign something this is like you're
just not going to school like did you
just stop showing up I stopped going to
school and nothing happened nothing
happened your friends didn't your
teachers no one like I was the kind of
guy in school that was friends with
everybody but not friends with anyone
like I got along with a lot of groups
um yeah
like I kind of got along with everybody
but like I didn't have like a best
friend uh I was into like skateboarding
snowboarding and
I was kind of transitioning out of that
into uh more almost like a preppy style
phase in my life you know cleaned up
cleaned eyes like a pretty rough looking
skateboarder longer hair big super
oversized baggy pants that was a style
at the time and I gotta clean my clean
my look up because I knew I need to look
more presentable going into my family's
business yeah right so yeah there was a
change there it's crazy to me you
realize that at what 14 years old
yeah yeah I was 13. I was I was 14
because I was a year behind remember
because I failed grade one so they put
me back so it took me out of French
immersion right and put me back into
grade one
just straight English you know what
before we go into that I just want to
ask you jack you've been on top of your
work lately what's going on you okay
yeah man I'm totally fine I've just been
using today's sponsor bittrex24 is that
the nail biting chemical no Grim that's
bittrex also known as denatonium bittrex
24 on the other hand is an all-in-one
platform that simplifies your business
by combining all of your tools and
softwares into one okay
why did you say Okay I was still saying
my thing so that means you're still
biting your nails
with over 12 million users worldwide
bittrex 24 is the most popular CRM and
project management platform available
you can manage all your projects tasks
or team Communications all in one place
using one of their 35 free tools and
another cool thing is that bittrex 24 is
available in the cloud on mobile and as
an open source software so that means no
more switching between different
softwares and devices and most
importantly no more paying for multiple
subscriptions it's completely free to
use so it at least makes sense to give
it a try and see if you like it once
again guys try it out for completely
free using the link down below and
optimize your workflow for the last time
again the link is down below in the
description 24 and back to the podcast
but to realize that it's probably
smarter for you to go work for the
family business rather than staying in
school even just having the mindset that
allows you to think that way at age 14
is just crazy you think that it was the
the faster maturity that you received by
working in the family business I I would
I would attribute a lot of how I think
today to the early and environment I was
you know witnessed to for sure my
family's business adults
you know I didn't have it like I said I
didn't have a lot of close friends
so
like don't get me wrong when you have a
restaurant and even though it's a motel
not a hotel nothing fancy but where I
grew up in Port Alberni like it wasn't
the place to go for the restaurant
industry like my parents went through a
tough time in the 80s when there was the
recession so my mom and dad sat down and
came up with the marketing idea which I
love because it's what I do now right
ironically
but uh my mom and dad were like hey you
know like there's this massive recession
how are we going to make it through this
and so I believe my dad and my mom sat
down and came up with like what if we
made our restaurant the the special
occasion place because everyone's gonna
celebrate birthdays or an anniversary or
whatever so they branded their
restaurant which was like like nice more
fine dining white tablecloth you know
steak Lobster stuff like that on the
menu
uh this was the special occasion place
to come to and that's what actually my
dad says got him through the recession
because everybody would come there for
for that
so it's kind of neat it's marketing
you're gonna get treated really well for
your birthday or anniversary because
those moments in your life matter to you
they matter to us yeah right and during
a recession probably very few other
restaurants were thinking that right
yeah I mean as far as I know my dad says
that's what's that's what got him
through that they would have been hooped
especially if you're only going to the
restaurant let's just say maybe two to
three times a year you're going to go to
the place it's known for like the
special occasions yeah so that's how
they go through yeah that's interesting
but yes going back to the original
question I would say that my mindset
from a very very early age was molded by
a more mature audience that I got to
observe and the consequences of how
someone would act I was always paying
attention because again remember I I'm
dyslexic I know this now I didn't know
it then but my ability to learn comes
from watching something right visually
seeing it happen in front of me and or
having a mentor like do it and then I do
it like you know kind of like like they
say like to teach a monkey how to do
something right you show them over and
over again and then let the monkey do it
they'll figure it out after a while eyes
like the monkey so always being in an
environment where I'm observing
something visually that's how I learn
that's how I absorbed information and
retained it more importantly so I grew
up in this environment of seeing all
these adults and their interactions with
each other as humans and I would see
like oh this person's body language and
tone and they were you know maybe having
a conflict with someone right sure
especially in the restaurant industry
like wait staff get in arguments with
the kitchen or whatever right or a
customer gets irate I was witnessed all
of that so I got to see a lot of
examples thousands of examples of like
human interaction and like if you do
this then that could happen right good
or bad reaction and so it's hard going
from that though to then school like
even when you were still going to school
how did you do that because I know for
me when I started working part-time I
couldn't separate like the work aspect
from school because once once I got like
a taste of working and what that was
like to be around adults everything else
in school just felt like why am I doing
this this is so like silly it's stupid
yeah like when I was
just working in my parents my like my
parents restaurant from a chores
perspective and then still going to
school
everything in schools didn't make sense
to me and like the what the structure
and it also didn't make sense to me like
why people my age acted the way they did
because
you know don't get me wrong I I was
obviously super immature in my own ways
too but much more mature than the
average person my age and so I'd watch
people share do things or tease other
people I got teased a lot in school a
bullied beat up
um I was a very small uh teenager you
know until long after I'd left I'd
already dropped out a few years later my
you know 16 17 year old age I started
going to the gym and that changed
everything for me physically but
yeah it was uh
it was weird I didn't understand School
let's put it that way that's why I left
I was like this doesn't make sense to me
I can't figure anything out I'm done I'm
out pulling the shoot
now I had a solution though I went to my
parents I said hey I'll leave let me
work in the business how much were you
making when you first started minimum
wage like a lot less like I don't know
what it was like seven bucks an hour
sure and what were you doing with the
money were you just saving it what was
the goal at the time like what what did
you want I had no gold the only goal was
to get out of school and co-work for my
parents okay I had no goal
um
my dad was after a couple of years my
dad became accepting of the fact that I
wasn't going back to school at least not
then and so he tried to
instill in me some like Financial advice
so he'd give me a book you know
ironically I hated reading but I
actually got my way through like David
Chilton's The Wealthy Barber uh Robert
kiyosaki's like uh race Dad Poor Dad the
cash flow caught quadrants and the more
I started to read things I was genuinely
interested in I would force myself to
get through the book or I'd read it more
than once because that's what it took
for me to retain that that information
because that wasn't the way that I
learned
but um some stuff stuck with me and some
things didn't you know like I have three
kids two of them are adults and my only
advice to them is like you're gonna
learn more from trying and making your
own mistakes than you'll ever learn from
me sitting here and trying to lecture
you it just won't stick the same way as
the pain and suffering and Trauma of
learning something or losing something
that you worked for versus me saying hey
don't do this because this could happen
to you
that makes sense yeah it does what's it
like trying to read as a dyslexic I
wouldn't know how to explain it because
I wouldn't know what the normal version
is
you see things backwards you just don't
know you see them that way here's a good
example when I first started vlogging
I would I had to do everything on my own
when I first started the channel our
Channel
so I started vlogging once I came across
uh Casey neistat I was like oh there's
this there's this way of creating
content where you just kind of like uh
you know video capture your day and then
try to tell a story out of it right
that's appealing to a mass audience so I
try that but with cars right because I
was that was cars were my passion I was
trying to get into
doing something with cars I would do
anyhow as a hobby but I was I was
knowledgeable enough from growing up
with entrepreneurial parents and seeing
a business where how it works that there
was benefits to owning a business and
the tax implications and all that sort
of stuff right like write-offs it's just
at the most basic level so I was like
well how do I take my hobby of cars and
turn it into a business so I can go
build cars and play with cars and it's a
write-off like it's all tax-free yeah so
I had to figure that out
one of the things that held me back was
coming up with a way to make consistent
content and I was like well I just
you know was
trying to wrap my head around that for
years and then I came across this
vlogging right I was like well this is
easy I could just go out and do
something with a car or an exotic car
every day and it would be like just
vlogging like this is what my life's
like driving an exotic car so that's how
that came about where I'm going with
this story is in some of the First
videos I made I would just go out and
drive around town and do like errands or
like typical stuff like at the infancy
of this channel you know what's it like
to go get groceries with a exotic car
right all the myths the things I started
with so I'd go out and I'd Park in a
parking stall in town where you'd have a
meter and you'd have to pay for it right
and I'd be like Oh I'm here in Victoria
British Columbia just paying for the
Lamborghinis parking I'm at meter blah
blah blah blah blah and go on about my
day then I get home later and I'd be
editing the footage and I would realize
I read the damn meter numbers backwards
and I would do this
every time
and that's when it hit me I was 33 right
so uh 11 years ago when I first started
vlogging actually no it wasn't even that
long ago it would have been three three
yeah probably like around 35 36.
when I first actually started vlogging
that's how old I would have been it says
36 years old when it finally hit me what
it was to be dyslexic because I started
noticing I was saying
business names backwards I was reading
more more importantly was just the
numbers for like parking stalls when I
go to pay for parking because I get a
ticket like I paid for the parking I was
too busy I was like whatever just took
the ticket yeah deal with it later no
I'm curious if you get numbers backwards
do they always appear backwards in the
same way or do they constantly change
around like couldn't you understand I
would just go from Back to Front instead
of reading the number from the top to
the bottom I would for whatever reason
I'd read it from the bottom to the top
or if it was you know left or right at
for whatever reason read them right to
left but in the moment like I have no
idea I'm doing it got it until I see
myself and it's captured on video
who knows that's what it that's what
it's like for me let's talk about the
the after you left middle school it was
because it was eighth grade and then you
went on to work for the family business
how do you get from there to the point
of buying a Gallardo that's a good
question
so
teenage years
um worked for the family business for a
while
then left that
then uh did some nor quite normal jobs
at other places just to have some other
experience so it wasn't like my resume
was like where'd you work for Mom you
know like uh because in a town as small
as the one I grew up in everybody knew I
worked for my mom there's no hiding it
so I wanted to have some other things on
my resume so I worked for a little pizza
place very briefly delivering pizzas
I worked in a sawmill I worked at a
Chinese food restaurant and some things
like that because I was familiar right
and I did try to Branch out do some
other things with the intent that they
paid more that was important to me I
wanted to be paid more money I felt like
my time was worth more I was a strong
capable male you know there were these
very men type jobs like working in a
wood mill that would pay like 21 22
dollars an hour because it was just a
more hazardous job right sure so I was
trying to do that and they didn't work
out for me
then I got into the world in my late
teens into the world of MLM businesses
right someone pitched me one I didn't
know anything about them I didn't know
anything good or bad like I just didn't
know anything about them but I was very
intrigued by the human to human uh
selling of a business model and the way
I was pitched it was like they were like
hey you know how you know franchising
works right and I think this is used a
lot in mlms probably still it's a great
analogy it's like well there's a
pre-designed business model you don't
have to reinvent the wheel right you
take that business model with a product
of Service attached to it and you sell
said product or service but you can also
franchise this business out to other
people and when you do that you get to
make some money from what they sell why
because you brought them in and you
train them and you help them learn about
the product and service of said company
right and you you know coach them or
continue to help them the more you help
them and find some good strong leaders
they can then go do the same and there's
this Financial structure of what you
start will continue to pay you right
type of thing just like franchise so I
was interested in that and I got
involved with a few companies and I did
quite well for a little over a year with
a company called Excel Communications
are you familiar with them no phenomenal
story really founded by a guy named
Kenny trout
and he was the fastest growing company
to go from zero to a billion dollars was
an MLM company at that time and they
wrote a book about him called the Excel
phenomenon it was out of Dallas Texas
and so they sold Telecom services like
long distance back when we had landlines
like this is before like cell phones
what year was this
well I would have been I would have been
like 20 so it's 24 years ago
so what is that 1999 yeah 1998.99 wow
okay okay so I got into that and when
you get involved with uh a good
group of people within a network
marketing company
they coach you on the number one thing
any human being on this planet needs to
be successful at anything a good mindset
your mindset has to be grounded and
found the foundation has to be in a
positive you know supportive environment
and Foundation you have to develop the
very Foundation of your mindset to be
like you believe you can accomplish
anything right whatever it is and then
all the other you know kind of like
keywords like being persistent you know
having discipline uh all that stuff
right so I got involved with a group of
people in that company who did that for
me you know they saw leadership skills
in me they saw it really good people
skills and I told them why because I
grew up in this business with my parents
work with people since I was a kid like
nine years old and um
they saw that in me and then helped
develop my mindset to being that of a of
a leader of a salesperson and all that
sort of stuff at like you know
1920. and I was with them through that
company because it eventually went under
on not because excelled at anything
wrong but Kenny Trout the founder
figured it was time to sell it I guess
he got a really good offer and he sold
the company to another company that was
severely in debt and all that happened
was this other company bought
the company I was working with and
essentially the debt that it had
eventually just like a leech just sucked
all the money out of that company and
not only did this company go down it
took the other company with it nice okay
yeah unfortunately so that was one of
two things one my first experience at
really doing uh like commission based
sales right so my first experience at
like the harder you work the more money
you can make
if if you can convert right and so I
also learned some very valuable
leadership skills
um that I didn't learn in the restaurant
industry because in the restaurant
industry you're serving someone now
you're still serving someone in network
marketing but it's there's a different
aspect to it because you're commission
based right it was a different incentive
I should say sure
you know if I was getting a piece of the
cheesecake sale I would sell a lot more
cheesecake at the end of the night right
or whatever it is you're more
incentivized so anyhow I went through
all that and came out of that going into
another MLM business with that same
group of people and just the difference
in that product because we went from
basically selling Telecom Services which
I liked because there was nothing
tangible tangible about it I didn't have
to say like
you know make this coffee right in your
home consume this coffee so that you
could qualify to get paid and blah blah
with the Telecom Services it was easy
because it was like you have a phone yes
do you use it yes do you pay a telephone
bill every month yes if I could save you
money on that exact telephone bill and
change nothing in your habits would you
be open to doing that
what are you gonna say no no you I don't
want to save money no everybody was like
yeah of course so it was such an easy
process what did the product do exactly
it's save people money it was just a
cheaper long distance line or or cheaper
Wi-Fi or it was the same cost to their
current Wi-Fi but the hook would be well
I know you you always go to warm Market
first right like friends family so it's
like hey
if I could put you on a different
internet service and it was the same
amount of money or less would you
support me and instead of supporting the
big giant yeah and people were like yeah
sure but then I how did they then sell
other people on it
like how much of your business was
selling them on the product itself
versus like hey this is also a good
business opportunity number one was
product so number one is you know take
everybody you knew that was already
using these products and services and
get them on our products and services
which will create revenue for you and
also the company which is why we're all
here and and then on top of that it was
like that also qualifies you you have to
have so many people on so many services
to qualify to even get paid right so if
you didn't have that in place it didn't
matter if you recruited people because
you don't really qualify to get paid off
of them at the full potential because
you need to you need to sell a product
and service you can't just sell the
business like there's no business
opportunity without a product I hear in
most of the situations most people don't
make money so were was the business
built around maybe that most people
don't get to that minimum qualification
or they might just get like one person
signing up or like how did that aspect
work or was there like an amount you had
to pay up front yeah so you would you
would pay almost like a franchising
style fee sure you know just like you
don't get McDonald's for free you have
to pay whatever it is back in the day it
was like a million bucks I think was the
standard number
so for us it was like a thousand bucks
and then with that you would get a
package and coaching and training that
went with that that you had to
facilitate and then part of the thousand
dollars I don't remember how much it was
again but with several hundred of the
dollars would then get kicked back to
the direct person who brought you in and
trained you so you had to do the work so
there was an upfront commission for
bringing people in
but then you the incentive to actually
get that money was also you had to get
their first I think it was like six
customers too
so you had to help them come in the
business get their first six customers
and train them and Coach them on how
everything worked and so they had a a
solid knowledge of you know how the
compensation plan worked and everything
you couldn't mislead anybody like at
least with this company it was very
straightforward so how much were you
making back then
in the MLM business yeah that was the
first time ever I'd ever made ten
thousand dollars in a month I thought I
was so rich really how long to you to
get to that point of 10K a month uh it
took me seven months that's really good
yeah I brought 1200 people into the
business directly wow I'm really good at
recruiting people what was your strategy
or like what was the scene talk to
everybody
I wasn't scared to talk to people I
talked to some I I had signed up oh I
was the only person in the company that
signed up over 200 of those people
called off the street off a sidewalk in
under 30 minutes how what like what walk
us through like from start to finish
what you would say what your thought
process was like what the interaction
was like okay
so
I would visually assess someone first
obviously because I don't know anybody
so you're visually assessing someone
based how they do their hair how they're
dressed
um and you can get a pretty good idea of
if someone is you know what type of
profession they're in like they're
wearing a suit versus a guy who's in
construction who's wearing like you know
Dickies and work boots and covered in
you know drywall dust so
I was really good at seeing people who
look like they were likely in a career
that I would say statistically
again I had no hard date on this but in
my head this is how I thought yeah
statistically this person's probably not
happy with what they're doing
so I just walk up to a guy maybe in
front of a coffee shop coffee shops are
good
so I'd walk up to somebody at a coffee
shop and say hey how's it going I say
good
and I'd say I I noticed you were in uh
you know some construction uh attire are
you working on a site close to here
and he would say oh yeah I'm just on my
lunch break grabbing a coffee I work I'm
working on this building over here I
said oh man that's cool I was like you
get up on that there's a scaffolding
he'd be like yeah I was like man I was
too scared of heights to get up there
and he was like yeah I don't like it
either I was like oh you don't like it
and he'd go well it's yeah I'm just it's
just temporary I was like oh what would
you like to do
and then
99.9 of people have no idea what they'd
actually like to do which is why they
are where they are so I'd say
oh well you know
is it that you don't like doing it
because you're not getting paid what you
think you're worth and most people have
never heard that no most people have not
been spoken to in a manner where
they've even they've even consciously
thought
what am I worth right what am I worth
when you look at what you're worth you
always need to go back to really what's
your time worth which is 24 hours in a
day that's how we judge you know uh you
know that's how we pay people that's our
pay structure so it's familiar
so you know like I would say something
like
yeah you know it's just like I don't
love doing it it's not I'm not
passionate about it and yeah I think I
could make more money doing something
else I said if I could show you how to
make more money like significantly more
money is that something that would
interest you
and like nine times out of ten that they
would say yeah for sure I said I don't
know if now is a good time like maybe
you don't want to get into it right now
but I could definitely show you how to
make some more money I think you're
worth more
you know you look like a smart guy you
know I think I think if you worked with
me and my team I think we get you
I think we get you somewhere where you'd
be a lot more happy than you are now
and he would say well I'm interested
like when can we talk about I was like
we talk about it right now if you want
and he would say yeah sure I'd say okay
cool can I buy you a coffee how about I
buy your lunch
so I'd buy the guy like his sandwich and
his coffee and I'd say I'll buy you
lunch if you're willing to sit down with
me and just listen to what I have to say
for 20 minutes if you're not interested
you know you have to go back to work and
go back to work regardless you know I
ended up working at a Furniture
um a furniture store called The Brick in
Canada and my sales manager had a half
brother that would come in every once in
a while and I thought this guy was a
drug dealer right like brand new
Escalade brand new Corvette
treated an ATM like it was this piggy
bank when we grew up go it as a group I
was like what's this guy do he's like
this guy's a drug dealer because my
brain wasn't capable at that time of
thinking he did anything anything else
this is also based on the way he dressed
and stuff like that turns out he was an
online marketer
specifically email marketing so he was
doing bulk email Mark commercial email
marketing with affiliate products so
affiliate products if you don't know
what they are is just simply you know
Huggies or
tied or whoever gives you the
opportunity to do advertisements on the
internet for them and they give you a
link so when a sale or a click or
whatever conversion they're looking for
is made they give you a piece of they
get they pay you they give you some
money for a different tiers of whatever
they're trying to achieve right you're
familiar with
so that's what he was doing
I learned very quickly the power of
scale so it was like cool was very
complicated to set up all the things you
need to set up to be able to efficiently
send email out and end up in the Inbox
and not in the spam folder that was
complicated but if you could do it and
you had a large email list the second
you hit send
well imagine what you'd have to convert
if you're sending 8 million people which
is what he was eight million people an
email that would go out in two hours so
in two hours he could reach eight
million people's inboxes
what do you think the conversion rate
would have to be if you're getting paid
eight dollars for every person that just
clicks that link and opens it up and
goes to the website like it was stupid
money the guy's making like 750 000 a
month
by himself
like that was like how do you get access
to those emails
is it sketchy that's a whole other
podcast so they uh just going back to
that when I'm the type of person that
when I find out that someone's doing
something like that and I mean that
intrigues me I my brain immediately goes
to well if he can do it I can do it
this is how that's just how I'm built
for whatever reason of my Opera like I
said my upbringing the environment I was
raising the way my my parents coached me
when I played Sports my parents were
like you can do this my coaches were
like you can do this right so I
was instilled and got that
self-confidence from a young age and
when I became a an adult you know and
I'd see someone doing something that's
that's how my brain worked
so I was super intrigued by this I was
like
this guy's living
truly live in that laptop lifestyle
so
he could go anywhere he wanted in the
world with an internet connection
[Music]
connect to his virtual mailing software
that virtually held all the data
and worked with what's called an
affiliate Network which doesn't charge
you anything to sign up you just sign up
and they have thousands of affiliate
offers thousands of companies that have
affiliate links to sell their product or
service or whatever right some are on
conversion where you have to buy
something to get paid some are just you
can get paid just for someone clicking a
link and opening up just for Impressions
right so I was like man this is nuts so
anyhow we ended up becoming closer
friends over the course of the the next
year and when we were hanging out he
always wanted me to stay longer but I
had commitments I had work on Friday
Saturday Sunday he wanted to go party I
was like I can't go party with you I
have a job So eventually that annoyed
him enough that he was like quit your
job come work for me I needed you to
come party with me like quite literally
wow and so
I eventually left
that furniture job I was at for four and
a half years and went back to or went
back into some type of a entrepreneurial
type of
uh situation with him that year was the
one of the most interesting years of my
life because I learned so much about
this new industry I got to travel with
him
um it was very exciting in a lot of ways
but it was also one of the most toxic
relationships I'd ever been in because
his partying was in excess and it was
too much for me like what's too much
well first of all we gotta I gotta back
it up for two seconds you know we're
talking when I was like 23 24 years old
at this point
um 25 sorry 20 23 24 25 was you know I
worked at that business for four and a
half years
so I would have been at this time when I
was meeting him
I would have been what 20 27 and then
going into my going into 28. so I'm 27
no 28 years old and I had my first
daughter when I was 23 my second
daughter when I was 25. so I have two
little girls
so my lifestyle uh was what was
important to me was to be a good dad but
to also get myself out of this financial
rut I was in and actually find something
that could make me you know change my
life financially because I knew what I
wanted into the 10 000 a month that you
were making well that was in that that
was in that MLM business that went under
so that was gone but what were you doing
with the money that you were making at
the time I was really reinvesting it in
what I thought was me and my business so
I spent a lot of it on travel got it
traveling because when I when I built
that business like we were going like
all over Canada all over the U.S all the
big conferences for that company was in
the U.S because they were based out of
Dallas Texas so I'd been to I've been to
Texas and Southern California back then
and
yeah okay so I spent the money on on me
and my team reinvesting it and helping
other people because I wanted I could
see it was working I could see the
multiplication you know the scale of it
was working so I was just throwing all
the money back in and then the company
went down I had no money yeah
um and then I worked at that furniture
store because I needed stability because
I had two kids so
party life what's too much uh we went to
Vegas one time
stayed there for 45 days straight he
spent just shy of two million dollars on
quite literally alcohol
and the strip club
in 40 and 45 days was he was he gambling
at all or no was it just like yeah he
actually made money gambling he was
quite good at gambling or lucky wow
probably luck and let's go with lock
that'll lock there wow just Reckless
luck
yeah yeah I'd never seen anything like
it since it was too much like so it was
like the daylight spend like of this if
I pitch if I could say like just picture
what you would think Motley Crue and
their Prime would be like yeah without
without the drugs he didn't do any he
didn't do any drugs he was just a smoker
and a drinker yeah
so
wow yeah he went away he went out like
nearly every night oh every day day club
during the day Nightclub at night that's
the crazy part was like
he would party all night get like five
hours of sleep beat me to waking up
because I'd wake up to like the smell of
like cigarettes and ketchups either room
service at three in the morning and I
was just destroyed I'm like I don't know
how much longer I keep up with this but
I was learning right I was just so
valuable and I was meeting contacts of
his that he knew and so I was just
willing to sacrifice something for a
little while right I knew eventually I'd
pull the rip cord because I was just
like I can't keep doing this but um
yeah he'd wake up first thing in the
morning and just be like
some people could do that though in like
three hours of sleep yeah he'd be
working all night get his mail out in
the morning yeah get his mail out in the
morning that that that email he'd get it
most of it going but it runs right like
once you send it you hit send it runs
now you do need to watch it you know
depending on what mail you're sending
because you can get error codes on
certain IPS and you have to get rid of
those IPS so it doesn't take out all the
like those error codes don't take all
the IPS getting kind of into the
postmaster side of things but
um yeah I was wild so he'd work in the
morning and then check on stuff during
the day and
and back then it was quite simple then
email got a lot more complicated but
we're talking you know
back in the wild wild west when it was
just the canned spam act where nothing
really happened so how did that then
lead to a Lambo how much were you making
with him
uh I was making like 10 to 15 000 a
month just working for him just just
sending out some of his email wow and he
also had other people besides me so he
had some that's how when you said when
did he work he would check on stuff but
then he also had like more versions of
me you know the minions yeah sure and um
yeah I did that for a little over a year
with him and then we had a falling out
over some like stupid stuff and then he
just I'm like I just can't keep up with
this so I took what I learned and went
this is what I'm gonna do I'm gonna be
him I'm gonna make
five hundred thousand dollars a month
right but I didn't I didn't make 500 000
a month right away but I started going
from making ten to fifteen thousand
dollars a month to making a hundred
which was mind-boggling to me I was like
I was just like this is crazy
um
and when you first get into that world
you're like this isn't really this is
like my dad would always say this to me
you know it sounds too good to be true
it probably is and I've learned don't
ever believe that
don't ever get that in your head because
there are so many things that sound too
good to be true that are [__] true
that can change your life so I would
tell you to be more on the side of
optimistic and be willing to use your
judgment and your morals and your values
to judge certain things but there are
plenty of things that sound too good to
be true in the world we live in now
thanks to the internet that are very
real so how did you start this business
though like how did that work okay so I
take that knowledge and I have a whole
bunch of holes that I have to fill
because the guy I worked with did all
this stuff on the back end that I never
learned I was just the guy as the monkey
on the front of the computer you know
pushing the basic buttons to send the
email out I knew that part I knew to
take an affiliate offer from the network
the HTML and all that stuff and the
links and I knew how to build it all in
the back of a mail program but I didn't
know where the I didn't have a list I
didn't know where to get a list I didn't
even know what mail program to use I had
to go find all that stuff and that's
just where you know willpower and
persistence and determination and a
little bit of saved money
and networking uh can solve those
problems
so I got my own
mail software called robomail shout out
to those guys
um I work for with them for years they
were phenomenal and you basically buy or
release mail software from these
companies and their techs help you set
up all the stuff that you don't know how
to do so is this like hey I need mail
software I worked with this guy I don't
know how to do any of this stuff on the
back end can you guys help me and they
were like yeah sure pass this and we'll
do it for you so problem solved mail
software now I need a list so then I
just started asking everybody I had
networked with after being to like
certain conferences in that industry you
know uh in fact here in Vegas affiliate
Summit West comes every year you
familiar with that oh so that's like a
big affiliate online you know uh
conference that comes to Las Vegas a lot
of conferences come to Vegas but they
come here they do West and East one's in
New York one's here and that's where
like once a year all the online
marketers come here like anybody doing
email marketing anybody doing Google ads
anybody doing native ads anybody doing
Facebook ads anybody doing anything to
do with selling affiliate products on
the internet in one way shape or another
I'll come to Vegas once a year okay
party it up like rockstars Network and
exchange information so I came to one of
those and once I had left that guy and
started networking with the people who I
knew and one thing thing leads to
another and you fill in all the gaps
next thing you know I was a
self-employed active email person myself
and yeah it completely changed my life
how long did it take between you
quitting that job with this guy and then
making your first hundred thousand
dollar month
um
fast
90 days
well when did you go from that then to
buying a Lamborghini at what point did
you feel financially comfortable enough
to pull the trigger so you pick up a few
bad habits along the way you always are
going to be some version of the people
you surround yourself with
all of a sudden you start making a
hundred thousand dollars 90 days right
you know ten thousand dollars fifteen
thousand dollars a month consistently
was like life changing for me making a
hundred thousand dollars was like
winning the lottery
and when you're doing something you
think it's going to last forever
so I spent it on all the dumb
experiences you could imagine like
I wanted to drive supercars so I went I
came to La for three weeks lived in a
really expensive hotel and went to
platinum back then Sam and the guys like
all the all the guys at Platinum
Motorsports and I rented a Ferrari F430
from them for three weeks and just drove
around La and like went to the club with
a couple of friends in fact I didn't
have any friends so I had like my my
Tech Guy
um a couple of guys that were gonna work
with me and do email with me because I
was just emulating what I saw the other
guy do right so I was like well I'll get
a couple of guys to do mail for me
excuse me so
I was trying to show them a good time
and just have some fun and yeah I just
blew the money just on experience yes
how was it like though having a family
and how were you able to do that though
like having kids at home and be like hey
honey I'm just gonna rent a Ferrari in
L.A I wasn't with I wasn't I wasn't with
the mother anymore at that point got it
yeah we had already separated back when
I saw the furniture store yeah this all
happened afterwards so I had like a a
custody of you know I was like the
typical every second weekend dad
unfortunately and you know she was a
phenomenal mom and still is and
we do our best to co-parent our
daughters to the best of our ability and
I paid child support and she didn't work
so it was also beneficial for me and for
her to work together in that environment
because I was ambitious and I wanted to
make money and she really wanted to be a
stay-at-home mom that was actually
always her goal so she was living her
dream in a lot of ways and then I
financially supported them the best I
could
you know and and was there for my kids I
go home I go home all the time so I've
been to every soccer game school
Christmas play all that stuff I missed a
lot because you have I made sacrifices I
missed a lot but I was there for the I
think I believe I was there for the
really important stuff yeah my daughters
told me I was so yeah you said you spent
a lot of the money how long did it last
for well yeah I mean it's a commission
based business right so it's like
there's highs and lows
um you could make a hundred thousand
dollars one month and then make nothing
for two months because
the IPS that you use to send mail
traffic on can get blocked by the email
provider if there are too many
complaints a complaint is based on when
someone sends you an email and it goes
to your inbox that little button that
says junk or spam that's actually
registering with the email service
provider almost like a informal
complaint because it's like when you
click junk or click spam you're really
telling them someone sent you a piece of
email you didn't want
so if you get too many of those based on
the volume of mail you went you sent out
if it exceeds the threshold you know for
example AOL that's who I mailed you're
only allowed one
complaint per thousand emails if you
have more than that threshold the IP
address that sent that email they can
just turn it off in the back end and be
like you know
well we don't want any more mail from
that so your IPS get burned there's this
cat and mouse game that's played in that
industry with the service providers so
yeah you could get your IP shut down and
then there's this whole warm-up process
of slowly sending mail and plus all the
time to set up the IPS or sourcing the
IPS and buying and renting servers to
set it all up on the back end that could
take a month or two before you can
actually get going where you're sending
mail to the inbox because the inbox the
only place that makes money you send 8
million emails out to the spam folder
you're gonna make nothing that's gonna
counter how much money it costs you to
rent or lease those IPS so you have to
do it right that's what was tricky about
it that's why not everybody was doing it
got it so even though it was
inconsistent though at what point did
you decide to buy a Lamborghini all
right so
I had done this for several several
years at this point and I got to a place
where I was just like my dreams always
yeah I'd have a Lamborghini I went to
buy one I actually wimped out I ended up
buying a Maserati Gran Turismo instead
because it had four seats and like I
said my kids were important to me and I
wanted to be able to bring my daughters
with me so
I kind of like I don't know you guys can
judge this like is that an exotic car
well I'll tell you back in
2011 that was really exotic for where I
lived on Vancouver Island so
I kind of say that's my first exotic but
then a year later I went back and bought
the gyardo and that was just a 2006
e-gear pretty basic gyrodo how much were
you making at the time that you decided
to buy a Lamborghini yeah at that point
I was fairly consistent at being able to
make you know the company I should say
the company I remember I have a
corporation set up yeah so the
corporations making
um around a hundred thousand dollars a
month
but there are obviously expenses of uh
IP leasing typically you don't buy IPS
you just lease lease them from a company
and servers and all that stuff and
cleaning of new data so there's new data
always coming in
the overhead wasn't excessive but it
fluctuated so if the company made a
hundred thousand dollars there was
probably at least 40 to 45 000 in
expenses
um
and then you'd you know not want to save
or not spend every penny of the profit
because you might have a month or two
that could be down I kind of figured the
game out at that point
so yeah I'd say on average you know
profiting the company was profiting
fifty thousand dollars a month
um but then
I made the ultimate mistake which was I
didn't pay my taxes for four years how
well man I'm telling you when you leave
school in grade eight you just have to
figure it out by making these mistakes
and so I finally got an accountant and
filed four years of taxes after making
significantly good money oh my gosh I
got a half a million dollar tax bill
and had like
what were the penalties 50 Grand in the
bank well the penalties were not good
um the worst part was this was at the
tail end of kind of my email career
because it was getting harder and harder
to send email and this was right around
the time that Canada was announcing they
were going to come out with the world's
strictest spam law and they did
so I always kind of felt protected
because I was in Canada and the Cannes
spam Act was American
and the odds of like them
cross-bordering coming after me for some
bulk email that was probably spam
was highly unlikely yeah which was
correct and
um when Canada came out with their law
and I lived in that country I was like I
gotta find something else to do plus it
was already getting really hard to like
maintain
the email side of things everything had
gone up in cost IPS had gone up it had
gotten harder to inbox you just burned
more you know IPS to send mail so the
cost of that you're just buying more
everything costs more so to make let's
say a hundred thousand dollars also end
up spending 75.80 right my profit
margins were shrinking I could see the
writing was on the writing was on the
wall for me for me anyhow right I wasn't
uh the other gentleman who taught me
this business was quite Savvy as a coder
he was a computer nerd at hard yeah you
know under it all he had that going for
him I wasn't that guy and I didn't know
who to get to fix this problem
so but at that time was the rise of uh
Facebook affiliate marketing using the
Facebook business platform on the back
end of everybody's profile most people
don't know that they even have probably
still to this day
and again people I worked with an email
who had networks I'd heard people were
making like a million two million
dollars a month doing Facebook ads so I
was like at this point like after you go
through that transition of like doing
commercial sales at or doing sales at a
uh you know Furniture electronics store
to all of a sudden having your eyes
opened up to this whole new world of
online marketing and meeting a guy who's
making half a million dollars a month
right of all of a sudden someone tells
you oh making a million dollars doing
Facebook it's like okay they're making a
million dollars doing Facebook right so
without any real confirmation or seeing
anybody's account that said a million
dollars right like after a month of work
I just believed it and started chasing
that and lucky for me it was true and so
I got into Facebook affiliate marketing
built a whole team around that and did
it right this time got a business
partner who is more Savvy with lawyers
and reading contracts so I brought him
into the mix and we built a very
successful Facebook advertising company
for a few months and at the height of
that I saw an opportunity to go full
time and take daily driven Exotics into
a bigger company and I eventually just
made a deal with him that said hey
you're running this run this company
keep it going all I ask is you know you
keep this going I don't even care if it
grows anymore you know we were doing a
couple hundred to you know quarter
million to three hundred thousand
dollars a month consistently with
Facebook
we had a bunch of employees we had a
tech guy we'd add Co ad copy people we
had guys that were setting the ads up
and then we had my business partner who
could run it all I gave them all my
contacts because he knew nothing when he
came into the industry I just brought
him in I was like look I screwed up I
owed the government oh by the way I
never told you that story I made 38 000
a month tax installments for 17 months
in a row wow yeah
that was rough I lived very frugally for
a year and a half and took every penny I
mean notice you didn't file like how did
that work I didn't notice
I've never I'd never filed it was my
first Corporation never filing at that
point like my Integrity wasn't my
integrity was never on that level my
parents raised me better than that yeah
no no it was wild to me that the
government wouldn't be like the one year
you don't file just like knocking on the
door but it was a brand new company so
it had never filed okay so it was like
they didn't even really know I existed
got it okay and then it's all all of a
sudden when I was like hey hey I'm over
here I think I ate some money they were
like yeah it was five hundred thousand
dollars and they want the money like now
yeah because they don't know you haven't
been saving so they're like yeah just
write us a check I'm like I have no
money
and the ladies like
that's a problem I was like okay well
I'm sure we can overcome this like I'm
still a capable person who still works
like what do I got to do and she's like
well how big of a check could you write
us and I'm like nothing because I have
fifty thousand dollars in my bank
account and if you take that
I will virtually be guaranteed to not be
able to make any more money other than
getting a real basic job
um so it's in your benefit to let me
keep that money reinvested in this
business I have going that's proven
which it wasn't but I told her that and
I will sort this out and I will do tax
installments so what's the longest
you'll let me do this for and she was
like here she was like uh a nine months
I was like I'm gonna need more in nine
months because we're already doing the
math
she's like
she was like uh what'd you say 16 months
I was like okay 16 months 500 Grand
divided by 16 months this is your this
is your monthly payment
I had no idea how I was going to do that
but yeah I grinded it out with email for
a year and a half and then was at the
same time starting to get into Facebook
and somehow just
made by the skin of my teeth
paid the government back started on a
fresh slate started the Facebook
business got my friend who was the
smarter brighter more organized guy to
be like that side of my business I was
like hire an account the first thing I
said to him get an accountant get us a
bookkeeper so from day one every expense
everything we have a p l we know what
we're doing right because I'd learned
from my mistakes so I wanted to do it
better this time and then went into
Facebook like I said got it going was
successful with it
then I left
that business to go build daily driven
Exotics I saw it as an opportunity to
start a second business and get another
stream of income right
well I learned another valuable lesson
what was that that just because someone
standing next to you as a business
partner
is running one aspect of the business
they might not necessarily be good at
running the aspect you're running
so being the creative person in that
relationship the person who really
oversaw like the ad copy the ad designs
right the visuals the titles and
thumbnails type of thing he wasn't good
at that and or having the foresight to
know and to Pivot or change a campaign
that's starting to go downhill in time
before you burn a bunch of money because
Facebook will take your money if an ad's
not working like you got to remember at
the height of our Facebook stuff to make
250 300 000 a month on Facebook you're
spending 250 300 000 a month you're
spending 500 or you're spending five to
ten thousand dollars a day
right because you're hoping the com the
campaign once you figure out the sales
funnel is going to convert at a hundred
percent that's kind of the number we'd
always aim for so to make 300 Grand
you'd have to spend 300 Grand
was a big commitment that's another
mindset shift that you have to
you know overcome to be able to get to
that place to do that this is one of
these parts of the you know the game so
anyhow when I left to build daily driven
Exotics in one year my my business
partner didn't change the product the
campaign we were running which went down
and he just kept trying to make it work
and eventually just sank that company
yikes and the worst part was the
agreement I made with them when I left
was
all I want is to be paid my ten thousand
dollar a month salary
okay whatever else we we make just keep
it in the company right I will go build
daily driven Exotics and in exchange for
me not being here and you maintaining
this and pay me my salary even though I
was part owner
because I'm not putting in the work
anymore into this company right but
still getting paid the salary I will
give you basically a percentage of daily
driven Exotics so at the end of that
relationship when he sank the company
and really couldn't uphold the agreement
we'd made well then I wasn't willing to
uphold the agreement I made that was a
big fight because he was in a place
where the company we'd built together
was now gone he didn't have a career
anymore and all the energy I put into DD
right by myself was starting to be was
starting to pay off but now I wasn't
willing to give him any of that
so we had a falling out there and I was
just like well that just is what it is
like I don't you think the company I
don't get ten thousand dollars a month
anymore like how am I supposed to live
now I got to figure out how to live now
I have to figure out right now before
it's even matured DDE like the YouTube
business it wasn't even at a place where
I wouldn't even take any money out of it
but now I had to I had to live off of
that business and I was back to making
ten thousand dollars a month
like the company as a whole so I was
making like just enough to pay rent and
feed my family again and drive a
Lamborghini was it was that the car that
you were driving in the very beginning
was that the Gallardo uh so the Gallardo
I sold when I had the tax debt got it I
used that money to fund me buying IPS
and servers to get through paying that
debt off for a year and a half so I sold
that car because I I screwed up and owed
tax debt and what was the car you
started DTE with well I started DD with
that with that guyardo okay and then
there was this period of like I didn't
do DDE full-time it was just kind of
like me trying to figure it out in the
background but I was pretty distracted
by the government taxes trying to start
another business
so it wasn't until I was successful in
Facebook that I was like oh now I can
shift my attention and go back to the
YouTube thing which I always knew was
like the passion project that could be
you know living my dream doing my hobby
all wrapped up in a company business
structure and so after uh that when I
went to go get back into
the dve I got a Ferrari uh scooteria f43
or a 430 Scuderia so I drove that
started goofing around with that then I
got a four five eight I had those two at
the same time for a bit and then um the
four five eight I started vlogging with
so that was really the car that started
the vlogging portion of
uh the channel the thing that was like
the consistent video concept that you
could do over and over and over and over
and over to build a YouTube channel This
Is What It Takes consistent content
so that's what kind of started that
there even though the guardo originally
was what started the channel there was
like this lull of a few years never
nervous about putting on so many miles
on the car wear and tear yeah I was
scared I was scared I knew all the
downfalls but that was the risk that's
another thing to being successful like
what's your risk tolerance
but how did you have such a high risk
tolerance because that seems like way
higher than most people would feel
comfortable doing
I don't know man because you I don't I
actually don't have the answer to that
many times I don't have the answer to
that yeah I think I think I was just
like I've been putting so many I I
shouldn't say I'd never been put in
anything I put myself in so many bad
situations that I found my way out of
that I was like okay well if I total
this car and it's worth 135 000 which I
I bought outright I didn't know anything
about leasing or the tax benefits of
leasing a car which may be different
down here in the US but in Canada huge
benefits people always like DD doesn't
own their cars
he understood the business structure you
wouldn't want to own our cars either but
um yeah yeah I don't know I just uh it
started slowly and again through some
luck
of not completely destroying that car
and pulling off some cool videos on
YouTube 10 years ago of driving a
Lamborghini in the forest in the dirt
which wowed a lot of people to the tune
of three four million people watch that
video and I made a second video that was
inspired by Ken Block's original
Gymkhana practice in his Subaru so I
went out with my guardo and got a little
dry log sort uh logging Mill parking lot
set up a little obstacle course and
hired a couple of camera guys and went
and made my version of basically
Gymkhana style driving a Lamborghini
which went viral again so I was like I'm
on to something here like driving super
cars and doing
borderline you know bad stuff to them is
getting a lot of attention
I just had to figure out how to do it
consistently because I couldn't keep
hiring a camera crew for three thousand
dollars a day
and beating on a Lamborghini and a
thousand dollars worth of rear you know
305 with tires or guyardo tires or 295
tires but they're still expensive
probably tires I was like the overhead's
too high like the business math didn't
make sense
so I was like how can I lower the
expense and create higher volume of
content that's where Casey neistat
changed my life man you know watching
him rip around New York City on a
scooter I was like okay cool the
metaphor is his scooter is my
Lamborghini
if that makes sense so if you remember
Casey and istat he would rip around New
York City you know like vlogging so I
just replaced his scooter with my Lambo
and basically mimicked Casey neistat in
the beginning to the best of my ability
he was a professional uh storyteller
incredible guy filmed so much of his
past life so he was very good at pulling
in old video footage and telling a story
and he explained that later after doing
like a year or two of daily vlogging he
made some how-to how to Vlog like Casey
neistat by Casey neistat he actually
literally has a YouTube video and
labeled that and I watched it and he
just broke it down and was like I would
Vlog my whole day and somewhere within
my day I would find one specific part of
a story that I would tell a full story
around which was like the three-act
narrative he would always suggest he
would say there would be an introduction
there would be conflict and then
resolution so that's how he built his
Vlog so I paid attention to all that and
I would mimic it but with a supercar
and it started to work people would
watch me just drive around in my car or
do weird things in my car how many
groceries at Costco could you get into
the front of a Ferrari just that was the
early stages of dumb YouTuber videos I'd
make back then though I remember that
anybody with a Lamborghini in the very
beginning was doing well yeah because no
one saw that I remember vehicle virgins
strad man uh Rob Dom
you and then Alejandro yeah they're all
like the big car people in the beginning
and Alejandra I think changed it when he
got the Pagani everything the 918 the
career GT first one on YouTube with
Hyper cars yeah I remember in the
beginning he was getting like a million
views plus per video yeah on taking
delivery of a Pagani driving The Pagani
doing this like everything just did well
yeah and I liked your videos too
admittedly when you get pulled over I
mean those are the ones where like the
cop comes up and hassles you and then
you then you disagree with the cop or
like the cops wrong about maybe like the
registration or something like that I
remember there's one where you're
driving it I think a cross border or
something like that and they said no you
can't drive this car in the U.S and you
said no I can and then going back and
forth with the cop on video it's just
interesting to watch yeah I mean
again
I think it was
you make a video
if you're paying attention if you truly
want to do any type of content creation
you're going to create a piece of
content and you're going to put it out
to the world right as the data set and
then if you really want to do this as a
profession you need to pay attention to
what the world tells you right the video
gets crappy views well probably no one's
probably interested in watching the said
type of content
but
the flip side is it does really well
then your little Spidey senses should go
off and go oh I should make more content
like this so when you're a fairly Young
YouTube channel
and you're striving to have you know
really more success if something pops
off you're going to try to recreate that
on some level so it just became aware to
me that when I got pulled over if I
filmed it no matter what the outcome was
the internet would want to watch it
because it would those videos would do
really well so after a while you just
just film all those interactions and
then you start to understand retention
so you're like well instead of just
sitting there and getting my ticket in
three minutes like the cop comes over
and lectures you like they would all
aggressively and you shut your mouth and
just you know yes or no sir here's my
license here's my registration take your
ticket don't argue with them and get on
with your day well you could stretch the
retention out by asking some clever
questions like what did I do wrong you
were speeding did you record that on a
measuring device yes I did what type of
measuring device blah blah blah are you
trained in said measuring device yes I
am do you know how they manufacture said
measuring device no I don't why would
that matter and then they're human
beings so you never know what you're
gonna get but nine times out of ten the
type of human that is strong enough
strong has a strong enough willpower and
confidence level
to be in that position because it's a
very challenging job
um and I have honestly huge respect for
the men and women who serve us as police
officers or First Responders or fire
department or paramedics or the military
um
but those personalities nine times out
of ten
uh or sometimes
you know aggressive
you know what I mean like if you chat
they're not used to being challenged so
if you challenge them you're going to
get a great
internet type of response also eat into
it the fact that you're driving a very
expensive oh 100 yeah 100 yeah yeah
because there are a lot I mean I have a
lot of friends that are police officers
and they openly admit like yeah a lot of
people will be jealous of you because I
know for a fact a lot of the police
officers who are police officers would
rather be rich driving a Lamborghini and
not being a police officer like being a
cop is not their dream job and they're
pissed off that this is what they're
doing for work
but this is what they're doing for work
and they have a badge and a gun and
authority and they
I don't want to say abuse it but
probably on some level that's a good
word
um yeah they abuse it and they'll tell
you to shut your mouth or tell you not
to think like I've had cops literally
yelling my window don't think and I'm
like hold on
that's your advice don't think and then
he'll reiterate yeah don't think like I
literally have a video of that huh and
I'm like that doesn't seem like and I'll
talk to the camera like that doesn't
seem like good advice don't think I
think you should think right and then
you get good at that like you get good
at storytelling what's going on and you
remove the emotion or remove the emotion
of like feeling attacked by the cop and
you just leverage it as in your head you
just tell yourself like oh is it this is
good for my business right because it is
yeah and you're already in the situation
you can't leave against the law like the
car by itself uh naturally gets some
really extreme reactions I like the
video the one you did where you went
into the one neighborhood and the guy
broke your windshield oh that's recent
yeah I remember that yeah could you
explain that tell Jack if Jack hasn't
seen this one I watched the whole video
I thought it was Wild Ones the short
version is are shops in Huntington Beach
but we stay in Costa Mesa so every day
that we're in town we were here for a
few days a week and then we go home for
10 days and then we come back to town to
work
so when we're in town we stay at this
hotel we've been staying at for years
now the one of the managers was a fan of
the channel and now we're friends we've
stayed there it's like our home away
from home so we drive from Costa Mesa to
Huntington Beach same route every day
and there was construction at an
intersection along my route and my GPS
because I just run GPS everywhere like
we're Canadian people are like how do
you not know how to get to your shop I
probably do but out of being a habitual
human being I just put in my Shop's
address every day
because I've learned in California at
any given moment an accident or
something happening can drastically
change the ETA of your arrival right
like at any given moment
you know the traffic could be like six
lanes blocked for whatever reason so I
just run GPS so I always know the
quickest fastest route to get somewhere
and so my GPS was taking me on a side
street because there was construction lo
and behold on the main road and it took
me down a couple of side streets and it
got confused it was like doing the
spinny thing I think everyone's had an
experience where you're running GPS and
it gets you lost it like starts spinning
and it doesn't know where you are I
think that's got something to do with
like the gyroy whatever's inside the
phone anyhow takes me down the side
street I end up in a cul-de-sac it tells
me to turn around and it takes me
directly back the same way I just come
so I went through I stopped proceeded
through a stop sign got to another stop
sign proceeded to turn left going right
back to where I was and I go back onto
this street and this guy
literally jumps in front of my car and
stops me and is just zero to a hundred
yelling at me swearing calling me names
and I'm like what is going on was my
first thing I'm like what did I do and I
was like oh this guy's just irate so
like doesn't matter what I did like I've
been in this situation a million times
and with cops or whoever
so it's just like
one second I grabbed my camera which is
like a Sony fx3 like not a small camera
I grabbed my camera with a big
mic on top and I turn it on I roll the
window down and I go
what's your problem
and he just kept going off he went off
his wife went off his buddy uh who who
he was a construction company worker guy
whose house they were working on that
guy came over and started yelling at me
and he wants a video for the rest but
eventually he told one of his workers
he's like over here talking to me and
another guy's talking to me and my car
is right here and he's telling that guy
back on the property that they're
working on across the street closer to
my car he's like jump in his car and
drive it away because my door was open
and the door was still the car was still
running and then he got out of your car
I got out of my car because I heard a
thud I thought one of them kicked my car
so I'm like I'm I'm 230 I'm 44. I've
boxed and or have some fighting
experience of 20 plus years like I'm
confident again in carrying myself if
somebody wants to treat me or my
property
disrespectfully I will escalate things
legally and appropriately so someone
kicks my car I will get out
someone wants to kick me I will kick
back
and I'm a good kicker so anyhow that's
kind of where it was going right I was
like not intimidated and the moment I
wasn't intimidated by three people until
they all surrounded me then I was
extremely intimidated by them and then I
was like okay this is probably a bad
situation I probably you know just need
to get my car and leave and then before
I could like the guy was like yeah get
in his car and take it away and I don't
know if the guy who hit the car just
couldn't hear what his boss was saying
or felt pressure that his boss was
yelling at him telling him to do
something but instead of getting in my
car and driving it away which probably
would have been a better option for
whatever reason he went in the truck
grabbed a sledgehammer and smashed my
windshield which is the most textbook
like click bait setup thing that so many
Supercar people have done that everybody
thought it was fake at first but it
wasn't because the cops came and
arrested said guy what car was it the
svj is the SBJ the orange and black one
that's here yeah what kind of
I hate to say it but 80
would think that's a good idea when
you're recording but he was recording
yeah that part well the issue was I was
recording in the direction of the guy
yelling at me who was yelling past me
also to the guy behind me so my camera
was like this and I was standing more
like like this so out of my peripheral I
could see my car
so when he hit it I heard it immediately
and I turn my head so when I turned my
head I saw him immediately but then I
was like a couple of seconds later I had
to turn the camera so I got him like
only three or four feet away from my car
with a sledgehammer like you should be
having a dash cam at all times the issue
yeah no for sure the issue with a dash
cam that I find is
you know wiring those into a car
sometimes or having to have a cable hang
down or whatever like I've just never
done one yeah I'm also a vlogger so I'm
always filming so I'm like well if I
want to film something I'll film it if I
don't want to film it I won't film it
and and dash cam footage isn't something
that would ever
I don't know use maybe it's a bad excuse
I've just never you really used one okay
yeah something like that I always have a
camera car's running and he you know
tits your window like just happening in
moments like that I definitely I
definitely regret it you know when
something negative happens it's like oh
I should have had a dash cam but the
truth is like I try not to put that out
there like again my mindset is
you know
No One's Gonna mess with my car I'll
park my car for all my supercars have
been parked everywhere and anywhere in
places most people wouldn't leave
anything and I've never had anything bad
happen to it like these are these are
the super like point zero one percent of
bad incidences like you know I've only
had someone smash a windshield on my car
twice
and the one before that was like six
years ago
so it's like it's not like I'm like yeah
twice seems like a lot only twice have
you ever had a windshield smashed never
I have really yeah we caught it on the
uh the surveillance at our house back
when I was a kid what happened there was
just a it was night it was like 3 A.M
and I had the room right next to the
street and I heard some crash sound in
the middle of the night and I didn't
think anything of it went back to sleep
woke up the next morning
just got already went to my car to go
drive to cross country practice and on
my way over to the car I just see glass
all over the ground and there was just a
huge Rock sitting in the the trunk of
the car somebody they didn't even steal
anything they just went up threw a rock
through it and then drove so is it
targeted towards you or was I have no
idea it seemed like a random thing
because I don't we would have no reason
to be targeted for something like that
someone literally just like they pulled
up we saw on the surveillance camera
like lights you know on the back of my
car their car was pulling up behind it
you couldn't see their car it was just
out of the shot yeah and then just a
yeah man you know like I'll admit like
when I was young I did some dumb stuff I
broke stuff that
was no Rhyme or Reason did you ever do
it in Southern California with a rock in
the back of a GMC
in Ventura I mean when I was a kid back
at home you know yeah but um what was
your craziest experience
in life just driving the car all right
well I was gonna say in life not paying
my taxes and having a 500 000 Bill no
experience a car experience
um
and that's tough because there's really
so many of them I haven't there's been a
few times I think you've been arrested
right or they never no no okay maybe
that was Houston I think maybe that was
Houston in the Bugatti Houston got
arrested on my camera that was it okay
so I'm confusing the two yeah that that
that cop was psychotic and that was in
Vegas right Houston Houston was not
overly polite to the cop but
so like freedom of speech you can say
whatever you want that's no reason to
arrest somebody like that officer was
abusing his power for sure that was here
in the by the strip that was here on the
Strip yeah yeah and we were in traffic
like just chilling going slow he was
just trying to get over and he pulled in
front of the cop and the cop was just
like losing it like perfect example of a
guy who should not have a badge and a
gun based on his perception of
power and authority like crazy
yeah but what's your craziest story my
craziest story it's really tough man I
mean it would depend on what you would
what your perception of crazy is like
well crazy could be you know being
harassed by Officer Pena and Beverly
Hills I remember quite a long period of
time on and off him just pulling up and
yelling stuff at us and driving off in
his Cruiser and then one day pulling me
over finally I was good flying with
Gordon f-spot yeah yeah and uh I would
go with him sometimes and just hang out
on Rodeo as he would film these videos
and officer Beno was like this running
it was an inside joke with the car
community and it would be what is
Officer Penny gonna do today and he's
always targeting uh exotic cars without
license plates or tents or exhausts
would always give tickets all the time
it was always the same officer too but I
want to point out yeah that that is
warranted that is his job yes so if
officer Pena as much as we'd want to say
is targeting sure yeah
if the thing he was pulling you over for
is in fact in the motor vehicle act or
code whatever you call it down here in a
legal or uh unsafe thing to do and
you're getting he's pulling you over
because he's noticing it that's his job
right like yeah but I always think that
Beverly Hills though every car has like
illegal window tints and no license
plate like that's half of the cars so he
would Overlook a lot of those and just
pick like the really expensive ones yeah
yeah I mean you know I just want to say
in his fairness or any officer who and I
said this to all our other friends in
the car Community like don't be the boy
that cries wolf I don't have to explain
that story but if you don't know look up
the boy who cries wolf like you don't
want to say you're being harassed by the
police
because you are you keep getting pulled
over for no front plate if you're
supposed to have a front plate and
you're not putting it on your car expect
to get pulled over right
whereas he would come up and say sir and
so again there's a side of him that
definitely also was targeting people for
sure but he would come up and say the
most random stuff to us sometimes
because we do the same hang out in
Beverly Hills hang out on Rodeo with a
crew and he would just pull up sometimes
and just be like
yeah you better watch out and then drive
off and I was just like
excuse me like
it was funny to me because
I could see how that would work on like
a 19 or 20 year old version of me but
like as a fully adult grown you know got
money in the bank doing well
got attorneys know the law you know not
doing anything actually not doing
anything wrong you know my car is from
out of country I'm a tourist I'm
visiting like I knew what I could and
what I couldn't do and eventually when
he pulled me over and was like yeah like
you have to have a California license to
drive here you can't drive on a Canadian
license
I was like oh I [__] got you like
really
really and he took it all the way and so
I took it all the way in that video he
gives me a ticket for not having a valid
driver's license and threatens me to
impound and Tow my car if he sees me
driving again yet he let me leave and
drive away with allegedly no license
which by the way if you don't know
Canada in the United States has a treaty
Canadians are allowed to drive in the
United States on valid Canadian licenses
the uh the police down here can actually
look up our licenses in the computer
system I even showed him my passport
that night as well and everything
and he even lied like he's just he he he
was the deaf definition of a crooked cop
because he pulled me over that he
started that whole traffic stop with I
ran a stop sign which I did not
so I was pretty upset but knew my rights
so right after he had finished his
ticket and we had left I said to the
audience well you want to see what
happens when a cop legitimately writes
you a bad ticket like you can go and
file a police a police complaint let's
go so I took the audience to the Beverly
Hills Police Department and went and
filed a full on uh complaint against
officer Pena and you know had a very
professional nice officer at the
department walked me through and work
through that process with me on camera
so you can watch from start to end got
it all of that anything happen to him or
what what was the outcome I don't know
what happened to him they didn't say
anything to me
um
uh the department did they wrote me an
apology letter like Beverly Hills
letterhead Beverly Hills police Dear Mr
fryer yeah have it at my house it's like
it's like you framed it I didn't frame
it but it's somewhere in a pile of paper
I didn't care that much I already knew I
was right yeah but yeah they dismissed
the ticket
and all that now the best part of that
whole story is Guess How many more times
officer Pena bugged me after that
probably none yeah zero
not a front play ticket ever not a
exhaust ticket ever and I saw him loss
after that he like and the the
interesting part was after that like not
immediately after but after like about a
year year and a half and that video had
gone from like 1 million two million
five million 10 million 15 million 20
million views and now it's at like 24
somewhere around there
um
yeah
they had because I had a friend in the
police department who's who's now
retired and left who's a sergeant they
had like a meeting about that video and
actually changed like certain policies
not just in the Beverly Hills Police
Department but in like California
Highway Patrol and like police
departments across the United States
they took my video and actually put
parts of it and other cop videos I've
done into like a national training
program that allegedly some police
officers take
um like that's like an online course
because one of the officers took his
phone out and like took a screenshot of
this thing and sent it to me a mileage
to anyone yeah so I could talk about it
because I never mention a name so you'll
never know but
interesting right and then after that I
virtually never and Dave can a test says
hey Dave we like never had a problem
with Beverly Hills police
like they just left us alone
we were safe after that it was
interesting like there was a weird
period where like not intentionally be
like one day we were going down or down
we had some friends on the opposite side
and like you were not allowed to do
u-turns on Rodeo Drive and for whatever
dumb reason like I just decided to do
one not looking around my area and there
were two police officers staring right
at me when I did a u-turn on Rodeo and
like they just didn't do anything
like we never had an issue no front
plate tickets ever again no your exhaust
is too loud ever again then I got one
ticket eventually like three or four
years later
yeah interesting wow they could have
known it was going to be filmed and then
25 million views you know yeah I think
you know like I think there was just a a
bit more you know and police have this
they have the ability to decide like do
I want to ride a front plate ticket just
risk versus like it's pretty yeah it's
like that's a pretty
dumb take it it's 25 bucks to fix a
ticket or it used to be I think they
changed the logist recently anyhow yeah
they stopped writing the dumb stuff
because they were just like yeah risk
versus reward yeah I don't want to end
up on YouTube yeah so uh last question
for you how is your business broken down
now
daily driven Exotics yeah so YouTube is
all I do for income well I shouldn't say
YouTube it's very generalized when I say
that we're really a media company so I
look at my business as
I don't look at myself as I'm a YouTuber
I say that because it's what's familiar
to the average person but really daily
driven Exotics is a media company
because my history that I explained to
you guys on this podcast is marketing
right it was you know I did some
marketing
um
with obviously email and then I did
marketing with Facebook like online
marketing I always wanted to stay in
that realm and I saw YouTube as a form
of marketing I was just I was on the
opposite end of it this time instead of
being the guy that places the ads on the
content I'd create the content let other
people place ads on my content that's
what YouTube does right they sell ad
space so
I want to make a media company started
with YouTube and then we saw as other
social platforms opened up we just took
and recut our content to be appropriate
for that platform so really were I
consider us a media company uh marketing
company and we take our content put on
YouTube we put on Facebook because both
of those monetize we put content on
Instagram specifically in the form of
reels because reels monetized
um we recently just got a snap show so
we're kind of learning how Snapchat
works and the algorithm works and what
works with our content how we need to
cut it up to hold attention retention
all that
so um yeah that's how we look at it we
prioritize it as YouTube first
Facebook second
and then it's like Instagram Snapchat
and things like you know like Twitter or
tick Tosh which aren't we're not really
monetizing but be everywhere why not
and
then from that
there's the ad Revenue we collect then
we do sponsors right where we verbally
talk about someone's product or service
in front of our audience and as a mid
insertion of one of our videos so yeah
we get to do all sorts of fun stuff but
essentially it's like we're a marketing
company make good content around exotic
cars in the lifestyle and
um yeah monetize it can you say how much
the company's bringing in per year like
in total yeah well it fluctuates based
on
um obviously how well our ideas are
working and it's a it's a revolving door
like what worked last year isn't working
as well this year because it gets
saturated really quick and the thing
that'll happen as you know is when you
start doing something that works it's
only a matter of time before other
people will copy it and that saturates
the market with the concept or the idea
so 10 years ago I could take a gyardo
and go drive it down a gravel road
millions of views I went if I went and
did the same thing today I'd probably
get a hundred thousand is only because I
have 3.3 million subscribers but if you
think about the odds of 3.3 million
subscribers and only 100 000 people
watching that it's awful so that just
tells you the the Market's not
interested in that anymore
so uh it always fluctuates but I think
our best year what what did DD do as
gross revenue like six million well on
that 8.2 I think best year 8.2 million
what year was that is it 2020
2020. it was insane that that year just
companies were throwing money at YouTube
because everyone is at home and everyone
was watching YouTube yeah
yeah and everybody still is I like I
think YouTube has a really long Runway
yeah
um I don't see anybody
coming up and knocking them off off of
that pedestal anytime soon yeah but um
yeah it's a it's a lot of work it's
grueling hours
um especially when you create the
company and the structure around
yourself as a primary host of the show
along with your business partner so like
when Dave and I are the really the two
key hosts and we're the guys that have
to facilitate being in front of the
camera we carry the camera I think
that's another piece of the business so
like a lot of people don't maybe fully
consciously are aware of when you watch
YouTube it's like some people have
production teams we don't like we have a
buddy who works with us who edits who
will hold the camera from time to time
but for the most part like same with
James or our buddy strad man like he's
everything he's the director the
producer the camera guy the sound guy
the actor
the editor the marketing lag like
it's if you're successful at doing
YouTube videos like kudos to you it's
the hardest thing I've ever done but
also the most rewarding if you can base
it around something you truly love as a
passion because it's like living my
dream every day which is I love business
I love building a business I love cars
I'm doing all that while getting paid
and then when I go home I'm satisfied
from like a hobby aspect so the business
is distracting because there's always a
business aspect when you're the owner
that you can't take your thumb off and
not pay attention to but for the most
part when I go home like I'm not
distracted I don't want to go out and
drive cars and take time away from being
with my family I can just be with my
family I can just be home which is great
because a lot of people don't have that
you go to work right you earn your
living doing said thing that maybe you
don't love then you go home and you have
to juggle being with your wife your kids
and trying to have some time for
yourself and go do the thing you want to
do to have fun well I get to do the
thing that I want to do to have fun in
my business when I go home that's
eliminated I don't have to I don't have
a need to want to go out and do that
yeah this is kind of cool that's awesome
I have a couple rapid fire questions so
I'm going to ask the question quick if
you want a quick answer just so we can
chop it up nice for uh for tick tock
okay let's go Tick Tock hot round so
what are all the cars you have now
all right uh list yeah Lamborghini
Aventador svj Lamborghini Aventador s
Huracan LP 580-2 which is two wheel
drive variant which is supercharged and
just got a race style body kit put on it
a 1999 Ferrari 550 uh which is gated has
a front engine V12 in it it's actually
the exact car they used in Bad Boys 2
that Will Smith and Martin Lawrence were
like dodging boats on the Miami version
of that movie wow we have a
Ferrari F12 which has another V12 in the
front of it and we did the world's first
top mount twin turbo kit to that car
because I was inspired by Ken Block's
unicorn
there is we have a Hummer H1 for the
truck side of things we have a cop car A
real cop car from Texas we bought from
an auction all the lights and everything
work has a cage in the back
um what am I missing for super pattern
720 GTO I have a McLaren 720 s that I
converted to my version of a GTR which
is based off of the original F1 GTR that
won the Japanese GT Championship back in
the late 90s
which I've had some bad luck with some
of these cars recently nothing I did
I'll explain that in a sec I have a very
rare manual LP 640 Murcielago which is
that's not my favorite car then we've
had a whole bunch of other cars that
have come and gone beautiful cars like
that career GT at one time other Lambos
other Ferraris how many Lamborghinis
have you had in your entire life
uh Gallardo
we've had a Huracan
two huracans three huracans regardless
three guyardo three guard us that's
right we had mine that's right oh more
we had
my original guardo original we had my I
bought my daughter a Lamborghini
Gallardo for her 19th birthday yeah my
gated your gated guardo and then I had
the Squadron Corsa and you had the
Squadron Corso which is the ultimate
Gyarados so there's four four there okay
and then go to Huracan the original for
her we had four huracans right is it
more than that no
no four because we had we had my
original Huracan we had the twin turbo
from Florida yeah we had the aperta
where we cut the windshield off of it
yeah
I mean it came like that especially like
that from Lamborghini
and then we have the current one we have
yeah okay so four and then we had the
Urus a nurse had a I had the Murcielago
I had a Murcielago you had a Murcielago
we have two Aventadors we uh and and we
had uh
Diablo SV ah Diablo so how many is that
total yeah I guess we could do it on
this accounting I think it's like 15.
put it on the screen right here why did
you decide to why did you decide to buy
your daughter a Lamborghini when she was
19. no no you gotta go you gotta go you
bought your daughter a Lamborghini for a
19th birthday I did and it was really a
combination of two things one of the
benefits of being a YouTuber that was
obviously gonna work well for a viral
type video concept as you was deserving
of it she's a really good kid
all three of my daughters are amazing my
two oldest daughters are very
responsible
um they didn't drop out of school like I
did they graduated they're just good
kids they one of them had moved out
which is my oldest and she was doing
well and she was coming to do some stuff
with Dad kind of like I did I went and
worked with my family in the business
that they had my daughter came and
worked with Dave and I both of my two
oldest daughters at previous previous
times have worked with us and so I just
thought like well she's working with us
like like let's just get her a car to
drive just a car that didn't last long
though because Insurance very quickly
sent us a letter after they had watched
our videos because they watch all of her
stuff closely and said you cannot have a
19 year old girl driving a Lamborghini
we do not insure for that really
wouldn't they almost anything of a price
they almost no they almost wouldn't
insure us because Dave was 37 and not
40. what not joking
wow that's how strict some of the behind
the scenes of running this company are
and again it's different for everybody
based on where you live and how you set
up your structure of your corporation
and all this stuff like how do you need
to play the game
to best accomplish the goal which is
make money but obviously keep as much of
it as possible right so yeah playing the
tax game and all that stuff yeah so
what's the collective value of all your
cars
at the peak uh was 4.7 million
and that's when I still had the career
GT in the collection and that alone was
worth 1.2 why did you sell it beautiful
car not good for YouTube and a story
fair if it doesn't make money for the
company I don't need it sure I would
love it for me personally trust me but I
don't have an ego like that in this game
it's it's uh run in a fishing company to
put food continually obviously when
we're past the food stage let's get past
that to create the lifestyle that my
family deserves my wife who's a
stay-at-home mom my three kids and
myself are working really hard you know
and my business partner and the other
people who work with daily driven
Exotics and their families all the
people that our company supports you
know I owe it to them to make the right
choice not the other one what's the most
expensive problem that's happened with
one of your exotic cars oh easy people
crashing our cars so my very rare gated
LP 640 manual Murcielago was
unfortunately crashed on a test drive by
the uh service shop manager
right after three months of servicing
and completely rebuilding my
transmission putting new synchros in it
which is still not fixed geez how many
of those cars are still in existence
other only like somewhere in the
neighborhood of like there were only
like 23 in North America yeah they're
really really less than 100 in the world
yeah and how'd they make it right
um
well they are the company we work with
with our uh financial side of the cars
so I mean they've pretty much for the
most part trusted us with any lease
payment size any car we've wanted they
pretty much haven't said no to it
they're great guys yeah how did it get
crashed
just honestly like leaving the shop they
were test driving the car well it was
still winter oh okay the roads were dry
however like I said when we've had snow
they put a lot of sand on the ground and
so when the snow melts and goes away
even though it's dry there's like this
sandal over the road and it kind of
comes in it flows and ends up in patches
because of people driving on the road
and so they just left the shop and we're
really focused on like oh let's make
sure the gearbox is working good and
maybe not so focused on like what's the
surface you know and all that yeah and
just murcielagos have a really tall
first gear got on it lots of power my
car was converted to rear-wheel drive
was an all-wheel drive back getting
kicked out sent them sideways and just
luck of the draw hit The One pole on the
whole street tore the whole car apart
how expensive was the fix
it's half a million dollars
and not fixed trying to Source Parts two
years I'm told to try to rebuild this
car
that's the biggest problem yeah cool
cool appreciate it man thanks so much
for coming on thanks for having me
really appreciate it I I that was a
whirlwind I can't remember what we spoke
about a lot yeah so have fun editing
that thank you
with that said you guys thank you so
much for tuning in really means a lot if
you guys wouldn't mind hitting the
Subscribe button maybe the notification
bell too because every Sunday we release
amazing episodes here on the ice coffee
hour and you can get a free stock thank
you guys all the way twenty thousand
dollars
cool thanks